Now, another part of the script was the track. And
we really haven't talked a lot about track so far. So let's talk a little bit
more about it. So here are four tracks with the restaurant script.
That really [INAUDIBLE] to going to restaurant, four kinds.
Here's a coffeehouse, fast food, casual dining, formal dining. You could add
more if you wanted to. Now in restaurants of all kinds, some even so common.
You have to go to a restaurant, you have to order some food. You eat that food.
You pay the bill. And then you leave. That is common to all of them which is
why all of them are part of the restaurant script. On the other hand what
happens in a Coffeehouse is quite different from what happens in Formal Dining,
which is quite different from what happens in a Fast Food restaurant.
So you may have specific cracks that correspond to Coffeehouses and
Fast Foods and so on. In effect, we are building a semantic hierarchy or script.
Here is a script for going to a restaurant. Here is a script for going to
a coffeehouse, going to fast food. And this can be tracks in the overall script.
Of course, we can build a semantic hierarchy of something higher than this.
We could think about going to, for social events and [INAUDIBLE] going to this
restaurant becomes part of going to a social event of various kind. Okay now
that we know something about the [UNKNOWN] representation called script,
the next question becomes how many AI agent actually use these scripts? So
imagine an AI agent that is hungry has some money and
decides to do something about it. So it may go into its long term memory and
find out the script that will be most useful for
the current situation. This really becomes a classification problem.
In long term memory a large number of scripts, and
the agent is trying to classify the current situation into one of those scripts.
Let us suppose the agent picks a restaurant script, and decides to execute it.
As it enters the restaurant, the scene it observes in the restaurant matches
the conditions of a fast food script. So it decides to invoke the fast food
script. This way the robot may walk down the semantic hierarchy,
first in working the restaurant script, then working the fast food script, and
so on. Now a robot could have taken a different stance.
A robot could have decided to do planning. Given some initial conditions, and
cold conditions, a robot may have used the operative that is available to it,
to generate a plan at one time. While the script is doing it, it is giving it
a plan in a compiled form. The robot doesn't have to generate this plan at
runtime. It is already available in memory in a pre stored form. This is very
useful because one of the central conundrums that we have been talking about is,
how is it possible that AI agents can't address computationally complex problems
with limited resources in near real time? In a complex dynamic world,
planning can take a lot of time. But if I already have the store plans,
then in working the script and executing it is much faster.